new black friday mirage cyka blyat Mian
Revo and more represent calm / PewDiePie
tamers what's up
epic look at this
finally it's somewhat finished I did the
interior as you guys kept commenting I
sort that system very epically look nice
now I also built a little Jesus
scares me every time oh my god Oh what
am I gonna do with all the eggs I know
what I'm gonna do with all the eggs
isn't that right that's illegal
oh my god I've never been disgusted
you'd never touch him don't sit don't
you ever don't you ever touch him again
I will look at me look at me coward you
will pay for this big machine I will
have to build an egg machine we'll do it
in a second I just want to show it broke
I don't know how this broke it doesn't
work anymore look I get made so much
cactus what am I gonna do with this why
did it stop I don't know either way epic
you can get a lot of XP by melting them
as you can see just look how much I
experienced up there absolutely
incredible but yeah our new house looks
really cool Garrigan loves it right here
again he loves it yo
you hear that pump and a pump and yeah
keep going chickens
um
yeah am I the only one I hear that like
go crazy got a stroke finally oh my god
I just got an even better idea
okay so think this is how you make there
we go
okay so this will shoot eggs right at
English stupid face stupid face don't
ever touch my child but what I realize
this we can have it the eggs actually
dispatch in here and make a forever
forever Ingmar shooting in face this I
get all the best ideas in this game if
someone told me hey look at me
that's right that's what I thought if
someone told me I was gonna build the
first egg face shooting infinite chicken
mechanism I would say you're a madman
but now look at me yes yes you will pay
for your war crimes angry got that
that's a lot of chickens I'm gonna go
and you think what about you daughter
don't worry about that Sven I was just
talking to Ingvar and it seems it's cool
now what's that well I heard him
what's that's been yeah
what's that but so and look in here
spend please look at me what it's when
it's for him what oh god he knows I
think he alright so a big focus that I
want to do today is actually getting
some proper redstone in this house I had
this underground lair which is really
cool here you can't see anything right
look watch this and it's late pretty
cool right I wanted to make like a
secret door for it the problem is a nice
vent nice the problem is I don't
remember
I don't remember how you make a secret
door I'm gonna try and do with honey
block I know they're illegal but it but
it's okay I imported it from
Czechoslovakia because I think that way
I can actually make a quite big piston
door hidden nests of epic without making
it complicated is usually when you go
bigger it's complicated in Minecraft so
it's gonna go here bing bang yeah I
think 5x5 is the biggest five by two I
mean yeah I think it could be really
cool the idea have this just one piston
right and then one piston pull it back
as such the problem is really just the
timing because it can obviously can't
activate now it's not gonna do anything
you know I'm I'm uh I know I know a
thing or two more than I used to know
god these things used to be so painful
isn't that right ahead so the signal
will probably come from here okay so now
we have a signal coming from the top
down here and another signal is going to
go in there however we need to cut off
the stream it sounds so stupid and then
put it in as such okay so that's our
floor right we need this floor not just
to go down but we also needed to go to
the side so we can go in so let's say we
activate it it goes down and then point
is this gets activated as well and then
pulls it back that works right however
the problem is if these get deactivated
at the same time so then I'm explaining
to you saying
it just doesn't work it doesn't pull it
back because it pulls itself back before
so this signal needs to hold itself and
then pull back instead of pulling back
immediately a way to solve this is to
put a comparator if you put them like
this it can hold the signal so when do
the singer remove it hold set and then
pulls it back try that again
remove holds it holds back it works
big brain so now if we give it a test we
have a four
we have an opening and what screamed or
by using slime is that we can use 12
pieces so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
without any extra wiring so let's try it
all right cool and what's even better
with my legal imported from
Czechoslovakia Hyundai block is we can
double the baby alright so I'm coming
home I hit the switch I go down I'm in I
want to go back I jump out I hit the
switch no one knows I'm there
how cool is they Oh No unforeseen
consequences
Aang why what did you do you shocking my
oh my god I can't believe it what a mess
they're machine guns in Minecraft I
wonder if any one of them went up the
meatball no no one found their way man
I'm so happy with everything I built
wait hold up a second
[Music]
oh my god
greetings there's a way to bring back
counsel of what the Sheep it's illegal I
don't care I'm willing to do it please
that I must complete the ancient ritual
no I can't do that okay fine I'll do it
I'll do it to complete their forbidden
ritual we need to travel far away
follow me child get in there you go
it's getting dark soon
we need to fly
oh god I killed them no oh my god I
can't tower can I miss it oh my god
[Music]
let's go to the top baby oh my god a
gift from the gods a sacrificial
offering I forgot to turn on the lights
and have much time
follow me child don't worry I've done
this before
are you sneaking I'm good you thought
you could it out
[Music]
blend my ash what up I need a
sacrificial sheep follow me child we've
been walking for years I don't care
it ends now I just need a water source
mm-hmm yes get in
I know it's your natural habitat don't
even pretend yes my child
any last words I'll give you one has
changed very well it is done Oh God Oh
No
he's back I knew it aah what kill it
what is happening what the ship it
wasn't supposed to be like this huh oh
my God he's strong
what there's so many of them there he is
what aah whoo come back here
[Music]
got him got him what's the real what
they're sheep I always wonder oh my god
I bet you don't even like water fake
water sheep oh god he's shooting sheep
illegal Oh God
stay away oh my god that's not what I
meant
Oh God so many explosions what the Sheep
too strong like he's strong pickaxes oh
no not this stop this is legitimately
hard haha yes found you I know Oh God
Oh God not the good stay away got it I
didn't realize you were so deadly I'm
sorry
[Music]
stay away I'm sorry what the shape I
loved you like a father love this bed
BAE please please please not like this
not like this it doesn't have to be this
way Oh God
he uses council of authorship against me
by the heaven you come from please what
the shine what the sheep's am I the evil
has been defeated Oh what did he drop
wool ring rainbow trail meatball new key
oh wow
I've acquired this strength yes whoa
whoa it's Allison hey gold
what's meatball nuke Oh what has
happened hey little piggy hey hey Oh
it was all a lie I'm back home
so I made it I made it you're again
amazing could it be possible is it true
[Music]
counsel of what their shape let's return
Hey look I was managed to shower finally
our house has been flooding for the past
couple dates that doesn't matter however
just in case you're wondering why I look
like a slob the whole video
I couldn't shower okay doesn't matter if
you enjoyed this video please smash like
we also have very important Black Friday
merch coming out suka be out meme review
we got it all
duffel bags look very nice take the
chance take the offer represent calm /
PewDiePie see you guys tomorrow bye bye